with the incredible Zach Sherwin who
just destroyed Thank You your crowd is
so good I know
well you're amazing I've always I've
always thought that we this is not as
amazing what I'm about to say is
occasionally your app Zach sure went on
Twitter and we're friends I will
occasionally engage Zach in a friendly
freestyle rap battle you're supposed to
reply as quickly as you can that's part
of you get a little bit part of the
culture for coming back quickly the
culture yep
I'm the poster boy of the culture our
micro culture huh so I actually printed
some up do you want these are all yours
those are yours and I have mine I
thought it would be fun to read them
yeah sure you probably it's hashtag FTR
be for a friendly twitter rap battle you
guys didn't catch on here's what I
tweeted of you I said you're like an
appendix nobody needs you
history will remember my name like
Caesar there you go people forget you
like they under anesthesia deal with it
crowd notice media and Caesar he's like
slanting that rhyme Pete knows what he's
doing it's called not around
hashtag anything so picking up your
anesthesia Ryan I fired back with not
feeling your booty runs I guess their
anus faiza you're misguided like
thinking Kesha is pronounced Keshia
because I had a friend who mispronounced
it that way and I had to have the thing
when I was like sure you've met my dad
all right you're so good let's do it
let's do one more okay
friendly Twitter rap battle you're shut
down this is mine you're not that you're
gonna think it's Zach Sears there's so
much better you're shut down like a porn
store in a Utah mall
not a bad opening line
I get stains out of carpets I got so
much results and you came back with what
you should resolve to evolve before you
resume starting you're unfit
species won't survive
call me Charles Shaar Winn Zack surely
our way in the next Charlaine hi this is
just gonna prove that you won crabs
naturally select me over you that's the
Origin of Species I'm the like a
colon call it the origin of feces it's
great and then I said origin of feces a
starting callback if so then well
done sir but I don't think you saw that
I didn't
hashtag ft or boot
youtube.com slash that ceiling